في السودان جنرالان يتقاتلان وكل
السودانيين والقطاعات تتاثر الحرب واجهزت
على ما تبقى من الاقتصاد السوداني وحتى
الزراعه مصدر قوه السودان تحولت الى نقمه
الارض الخصبه التي تتمتع بالدفء والانهار
باتت عاجزه عن توفير غذاء الشعب السوداني
كان هذا قبل النزاع اما الان فالوضع ازداد
سوءا مزارع السودان البعيده مئات
الكيلومترات عن الخرطوم تعاني مما تشهده
الشوارعها من اقتتال
[موسيقى]
المناطق الزراعيه في ولايه القضارف كانت
الاكثر تاثرا وبسببها بات شبح الجوع يخيم
على نصف الشعب السوداني بحسب الامم
المتحده في الواقع حقول الجزيره ايضا
تعاني من تداعيات الحرب هي اقرب الى
الخرطوم لكنها تتمتع بميزه قربها من
الانهار وقد تصمد اطول قليلا لكن الامر
مختلف بالنسبه للجارف موسم الامطار حل منذ
ايام ولم يعد هناك مجال لتدارك الوضع فمن
لم يزرع حتى الان لن يحصد شيئا وعلى عكس
مشروع الجزيره اراضي الجدارف يستغلها
افراد وقبائل لكنها تعتمد على الدوله في
التمويل والحصول على البذور اما العمال
فهم في العاده عمال موسميون قادمون من
ولايه اخرى للعمل في المزارع وبحكم الواقع
هم اول متضررين
[موسيقى]
ورغم امتلاكي ولايه الجدار في تربه سوداء
خصبه بسبب قربها من اثيوبيا فهي تستفيد من
الامطار الموسميه الا ان قسوه فصل الجفاف
جعلت السكان لا يستقرون فيها والسبب شح
المياه اذ يصلون نصيب الفرد الواحد من
المياه العذبه تسعه لترات يوميا فقط وهو
اقل بالنصف من المعدل الموصى به من قبل
منظمه الصحه العالميه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات